different worlds yesterday just the  three players in the oslo arena  winning their matches and today all of  them losing their matches  now all of them losing as well in normal  time so not even zero points  there's actually zero points in the oslo  arena today yeah yeah all the other  points are out there in the world okay  for other players  and uh duda trying one final trick he  gives up his rook he's hoping for some  stalemate ideas but look at that  celebration from rajabov he's about to  deliver checkmate the azeri player takes  it ah devastation for young christophe  duda but what a performance bye timor  roger  what can you say about timor ivanka what  a performance by him today yeah i mean  he's he's such a fantastic player i mean  when you give him a positional edge he  is able to turn the screw masterfully i  mean i've been very impressed by his  play and i i kind of guessed that his  strategy would be against such a  creative energetic player such as do